thank you very much is it coming through
the mic okay okay cool I did briefly
turn it off while I left the room yeah
as you can tell by my voice the London
he's referring to his not London Ontario
it's the big one the original I feel
very fortunate to now live in Toronto I
moved here in March I love the city and
it was a really cool this is my first
talk that I've actually done here it's
funny when you move somewhere you tend
to travel more away from it to do talk
so this is this is really cool
typescript state of the union this union
types and typescript so I kind of felt
like that was a nice way to weave that
in there maybe I should have done State
of the Union type but essentially what I
wanted to talk about because I feel like
this maybe hasn't been brought up for a
while is just read wresting typescript
and particularly a conference like like
this one where we're talking about all
kinds of topics which affect development
and JavaScript's development and as a
whole I think typescript might be one of
those things that you've come across and
maybe discounted as not being the right
thing for you maybe not helpful for your
particular situation may be too complex
may be too different from the JavaScript
that you know and love so I want to try
and redress that today and maybe
reintroduce you to typescript and we'll
cover a little bit about what the the
state is on our current version version
3.1 and what that's like to get started
with when you already know a bit of
JavaScript when you already know how to
get started with JavaScript how can we
add typescript to a project how how can
it help us write the best JavaScript we
can so my obligatory all my slides
aren't coming up yet
just imagine what my slides looked like
they're great that was blue there we go
that's my twitter handle seven we've
done the about me so you can look me up
online I have some typescript courses on
typescript courses com so you can learn
typescript in depth from start to finish
if you want to after the talk and the
things I want to talk about today is
kind of I just bring you up to speed on
the history of typescript how we got
here some of the major milestones that
have happened in the project what
typescript looks like when you compare
it to JavaScript as a language
a little bit about how it works so some
of the core pieces of the framework and
how the different bits of architecture
help you when you're writing your code
and some of the latest and greatest from
the projects from the team from the
open-source community and some of the
things that might be coming up in the
near future so how many people in the
room have used typescript before Oh a
lot more than I was expecting
that's really cool so I will try and
make it a little little more interesting
to you but it may be useful for you to
see some of the things of how we
introduce typescript these days in the
project because it has changed quite a
lot there's a lot more power there now
so literally only yesterday the
typescript team tweeted that it six
years old it's a happy birthday to
typescript as of yesterday which is
pretty cool so it went straight into my
slide deck I think it's crazy to think
that the project is that old and doing
so well the the growth curve of it has
been truly incredible if we look back at
the early days in 2011 there was this
internal project in Microsoft called
Project Strada
and the scope was pretty broad it was
about bringing all kinds of power to
JavaScript applications because the
engineers at Microsoft was struggling to
build applications which scaled
unusually for Microsoft at the time
because if you think about what
Microsoft was like in 2011 versus what
we know about it today
open-source was not really a core part
of how Microsoft operates it they were
kind of the kings of proprietary stuff
and locking things behind behind
proprietary firewalls and that kind of
stuff but the Strada team and as housed
burg particular recognized that going
open-source very early on was going to
be important to the success of the
project it wasn't quite the open-source
that we know today they use the
Microsoft tool to be open source and it
was kind of like yeah you can see the
source but you're not going to be
contributing to this thing you can look
at it but we don't we're not we can't
accept PRS or anything like that so that
that did start to change when they move
to github in 2014 so they launched in
2012 as we know yesterday six years ago
they refactored their pass or a couple
of a couple of steps along the way and
then in 2014 they finally moved to
github so that that's when it moved from
being just open source to what they
would describe as open development now
anybody from the community could open a
PR file an issue it would be in the same
arena as the developers working on the
project itself which is really really
cool and then I would say that probably
the next most significant milestone came
when Microsoft and Google worked
together when the angular framework was
going through its major rewrite so
angularjs became angular it was version
2 of the framework they kept the same
name drop the j/s angular they really
wanted to build in some extra features
on top of JavaScript so they were going
to build their own proprietary language
called at script and basically at script
was just a tiny amount of features on
top of what we already understood to be
typescript so fortunately they were able
to work together
typescript introduced the missing
features into typescript such as
decorators and angular was able to be
written in typescript instead of being
developed using a proprietary language
called app script which was really
really good and at this point in time
you can see that both the framework of
angular and and the language of
typescript took off together which is
really really cool so as I said
typescript exists because writing
scalable JavaScript applications is
difficult a strapline of typescript is
to write JavaScript that scales and I
think one thing that is easy to conclude
is that it's not the JavaScript that I
know it's not the JavaScript that I care
about but I think a core thing about
typescript this is not trying to replace
JavaScript it's not trying to reinvent
the language it's about embracing and
enhancing it and when we talk about the
type system in a little bit will
understand how they've actually
sacrificed some things from classical
type theory to embrace the dynamic
nature of JavaScript for the benefit of
everyone that uses it and the other key
thing is that typescript has always been
about empowering tooling there are other
statically typed tool it tools for
JavaScript for example flow is an
example and they've taken a different
prototype script I'm not saying it's a
better approach or worse approach
they've taken a different approach but
one of the key things typescript always
wanted to do was be able to use the
knowledge of types to provide you with
tooling to help you write your
JavaScript code so this is this is just
borrowed from a slide from Anders the
kind of godfather of typescript and
these are the key points that they want
to strive towards in their project as
maintainer x' of typescript
within Microsoft so as I mentioned it's
more than just open source they want to
develop in the open they want people to
contribute to it and they want to take
feedback from the community wherever
possible in the very early days there
wasn't really a constraints on what can
we add whereas now they really want to
track what echo scripts in other words
javascript is doing so features they get
proposed for the language like for
example in es2015 or es6 as it was known
originally when we had classes
introduced for the first time they want
to be compatible with any of those
features that come into javascript and
they don't want to be ahead of that
anymore they don't want to be inventing
proprietary typescript things in the
language which then don't match up with
JavaScript the language instead they
want to innovate in the type system so
that is their domain some of the some of
the stuff they're able to do in the
typescript
it's in the type system is mind boggling
and so so cool and that is their arena
where they can experiment where they can
build really cool stuff they're not
going to be doing that with the core
language structures and values I mention
about the tooling they are actually part
of the same organization within
Microsoft that is the producers visual
studio code how many people here use
Visual Studio code is their primary nice
cool so we all benefit from typescript
being a part of that same team they
develop with that team and it means that
they can really stay in sync with what's
happening there and community community
community this Anders mentioned this
about Steve Ballmer but going developers
developers developers they want to
change it to a community community
community so I'll talk about that in a
little bit crazy popular the one of the
c-level people from NPM did some
research based on on a survey of more
than 16,000 users 46% of them reported
using typescript so I think type scripts
done a really good job of being a part
of the NPM ecosystem without trying to
replace it and just slotting into the
existing setup so it's amazing to know
that so many developers obviously in a
relatively small sample compared to the
whole of NPM but it's amazing that so
many people using it downloaded over 10
million times a month very very popular
apparently more typescript projects were
created on github in 2017 than C++
projects even so it's it's kind of crazy
how how much the growth curve has gone
upwards I've always wanted to be the
douche that quotes himself on a slide
and I've never done it before so I
thought today was the day so I tweeted
this last night because I thought it was
a really good point I think the example
I love to use when people talk about I
don't want to use typescript because I
don't want to deal with types is that
types already exist in JavaScript
whether you choose to use tooling that
can understand them or not and the way I
can prove to you that you deal with
types all the time is with this line of
code naturally you don't usually
literally write the value undefined and
try and call as a function but ending up
in a position where you are trying to
call a value which has not been defined
and therefore defaults to the value and
defined a new train call as a function
happens all the time and if it wasn't
enough of a clue that the type of error
that you're getting is called the type
error if you look at the echo script
definition the specification as I know
we all do before we go to bed every
night we read the spec you will have
there's a whole section dedicated to the
Ekman script types these are things like
undefined null boolean object symbol
function those are the kind of types
that exist in the language they have
corresponding values and you don't deal
with those types through syntax unless
you use a tool like typescript that's
when you can start to take control of
some of those things and try and get the
tooling to protect you so that you don't
end up at runtime getting this feedback
instead you get the feedback at author
time so with this understanding of types
that types can give us as I mentioned
they work closely with Visio
it powers lots of different things we
take for granted inside of our editors
if we didn't have an understanding of
the types of our programs we couldn't
jump to where they were defined we
couldn't be typing the method name and
it autocompletes the rest of it for us
we couldn't automatically refactor code
we couldn't command click or
control-click on Windows to jump around
our codebase
I simply wouldn't be possible because
behind the scenes there needs to be an
appreciation of how the symbols in our
program interacts with one another this
exploded in popularity I am NOT a huge
developer I've never written any of you
but I happen to notice that the guy that
created it ever knew he tweeted he's a
blog post just announcing his plans for
the next version of the framework and
he's actually going to be writing it in
typescript so even I would say even even
frameworks with j/s in the name are
going to be written in typescript behind
the scenes and one of the one of the
really powerful things about this is it
doesn't change anything about the view
Jay s development experience it will
improve it if you're using typescript
but if you're not using typescript the
fact that the authors have used
typescript doesn't impact your code and
I think that's a really powerful
property which relates to the tooling
aspects which the typescript team have
managed to maintain so the the knowledge
of the the relationship with angular is
pretty well known I think they have a
very tight relationship the fact that
Vijay s is being written in typescript
from now on is really really cool at
Google there's only a handful of
languages that are allowed to be used
periods you just can't you can't just
decide I'm gonna use Scala today or
anything like that at Google they very
tightly control the languages they're
available for use because they operate
on this model of having essentially all
of their code in one giant mono repo so
it wouldn't work at all if developers
had the freedom to just add languages to
that mono repo whenever they saw that
would break their tooling and break
their assumptions typescript has now
been approved as one of the five or so
languages that are actually allowed to
be developed with at Google so that
shows how far it's come and the
relationship with with the team there
and
huge companies are using reactant
typescript so even though Facebook and
Microsoft might not have had an explicit
brain trusts in the same way that Google
and Microsoft did for the angular stuff
the Microsoft team have worked hard to
make sure that there is a special
appreciation of react inside of the
typescript code base so if since very
early on
typescript has supported JSX syntax they
call it TSX because you use a dot TSX
file extension but recently they've
really tried to improve the react
development experience when you're using
typescript as well so that's I think a
powerful thing and it's being used at
scale at Microsoft but also other other
large corporations such as slack so if
you're sat there thinking while I'm a
react developer so maybe typescript
isn't the right fit for me that's that's
simply not the case you can get an
enormous amount of benefit from it and
there are of course many many many other
frameworks the slide would go on forever
but some big ones that are written in
typescript dojo and aralia
there's plenty more and of course there
is absolutely no requirement to use a
framework of any kind you can write very
very strong JavaScript code using
typescript without any frameworks at all
so how easy is it to get running with
typescript that's what we're gonna now
see in a demo hopefully so hopefully you
can read this ok it's pretty bright I
definitely do not develop with a bright
white theme I value my retinas so this
is just for your benefit I promise so
here we have a JavaScript file I
wouldn't pay too much this is actually
inside the project that is running my
slide deck so don't pay attention to the
folder structure of the files too much
so I'll just move that over a bit oh no
now we're in trouble there we go
cool so I have a function here it's
pretty pretty great program I'm quite
proud of this so first name variable
James I'm gonna be logging it altima
leave I'm going to be doing a transform
only I'm gonna be turning it into
uppercase who can spot the bug
exactly it's not easy humans suck at
reading codes and immediately
understanding as if we're as if we're
executing in our minds it's not easy I
have deliberately written uppercase in
the casing that I've written it in
everywhere to even influence your eyes
to think that that is the correct way of
writing uppercase so obviously you can
write uppercase like that but it means
that it's influenced your thinking
around this C so this C it should be a
capital C so this in this method to
upper case with this casing does not
exist on the string prototype so this
would be a runtime bug that would make
it all the way to production you all
passed it that you were all my pull
request reviewers you said approve I
merged it shipped its uses and it's
broken so how can we improve this using
typescript and I don't mean that we
start installing the typescript compiler
and compiling our code and having a dist
folder which we then need to none of
that how can we just add a little bit to
make our program better so what we can
do is type script actually understands J
s doc annotations so these might be
things that you've used in the past to
document your code but they can do a bit
more than that because they have such
expressive syntax so if I add a
parameter
I'm not used to this syntax theme so
that looks correct to me so if I had a
pram here standards jsoc syntax
hopefully that is I'm just saying the
name of my parameter I'm saying its type
if I now hover on s you can see that
these are studio code somehow now knows
that that's a string so if I just take
that away again go back to my s this was
of type any before because there was
absolutely no way for it to know what
the type was but now I've added just a
document just a comment documentation
comments and the the editor has been
able to pick up that this is a string so
that's really really cool
this is because even when you're using
JavaScript directly the typescript
language server which will talk about
service but it will talk about a bit
later on is running in the background
so we still don't have any errors with
our to uppercase so even though things
have improved a little bit so if I were
to use s here I might be able to get
some more information here but we've not
really we've not necessarily turned on
all the error handling that we want so
if I move on to number two that's what I
state look like good what I'm going to
do now is I'm gonna still be using a
JavaScript file I'm not going to be
adding the types compiler explicitly yet
but I'm going to go up to the top of the
page and I'm gonna add another comment
which I'm gonna be adding one of these
flags to this is TS check so if I enable
TS check so it's a normal comment again
it's not affecting my runtime JavaScript
code but as you can see what's now
happened is that language service with
the typescript compiler that was already
running in the background I've now told
it with this comment please give me
things you know are definitely wrong so
it's not as precise and it's not as
noisy let's say as the typescript
compiler when you run it completely it's
not going to tell you about everything
but things where it knows you're you've
definitely made some kind of mistake
like with this method to uppercase it's
going to give you some feedback so here
you can see it's even been able to
recognize it's doing some like fuzzy
pattern matching on the methods which
are available on that prototype and to
uppercase with a capital C matches the
best so it's even suggesting the fix for
me so I can come in here I can fix the
bug I can reopen the PR I've not changed
our development pipeline I've not
changed our build process all I've done
is add two lines of comments to my
JavaScript program and now when I submit
it to you and you all blindly approve it
it will go in then the bug will be fixed
so that's great so so far we've got
started with typescript almost without
using typescript at all explicitly which
is really really powerful and these are
some of the new things which have come
to typescript within the last few years
so moving on to our next example we are
still dealing with I can't remember what
my next example was
oh I know what my cousin six example was
so imagine now I did this ahead of time
just so that I wasn't wasting anyone's
time but imagine now that I've added a
TS config dot JSON file to my project so
the way that you would do this is you
would install the typescript compiler
via a node modules so I've done that
that's the reason I didn't want to do
this live was because installing from no
modules on a on a Wi-Fi can actually not
not easy here so I've installed
typescript and pile of I know modules I
then can invoke so I could use em px for
example to invoke my local no modules
TSC dash dash in it so if I run that
that will generate what we're looking at
here that will generate this TS config
JSON file and as you can see the way
that they generates it these days is
they add all of these comments
explaining what the different properties
do what the different configurations do
which is really really cool it used to
be a little cryptic as to what all the
compiler options did now they actually
tell you so if you're going to be
starting a new typescript projects I
would highly recommend you use TS c in
it it's very very cool so all i've done
here is i've added
i've instead i've uncommented the flag
which is allow j s true so as you can
see this allows javascript files to be
compiled i've explicitly told it which
javascript file i want to include in my
my bundle but if i were to run MPX TS c
to invoke the typescript compiler i'm
not in the right folder one of the
reasons I'm using MPX is so it will
traverse up to my node modules so you go
so I've set the out dere to dist and
I've invoked my 4j s so here you can see
this is my input with my TS check and my
string comment and this is my output
they are identical essentially all
typescript has done has nicely added the
use strict directive for me because I
forgot to add that myself in the
JavaScript code but essentially it's the
same output so I all I would say to you
is whenever you have these conversations
at work or with your colleagues this is
how lightweight typescript has become on
top of your JavaScript Eve
when I do use the typescript compiler I
don't need to make a TS file I can still
have it as a J's file I can enable the
flag allow J s true and it will barely
change the output of my JavaScript if I
don't want it to I can do more work on
this file obviously as part of a build
process but this is fine for now this is
a good start so I'm gonna close this if
I wanted to go a step further and change
this to be a TS file here you can see
what I've done is I've taken my J s
comment and I've actually added it as a
type annotation so it's a colon string
syntax instead of the parameter in in
there so it's now actually syntax in my
program and I no longer need the TS
check comment because if I were to make
that same mistake it's gonna be able to
tell me directly because I'm running in
a typescript context already cool so I'm
sure I went on way too long on that
particular example but hopefully I think
that's one of the most key things that
people have skipped is we haven't gone
back and taken stock of how easy it is
to get started with typescript these
days so the type system itself I think
it's worth noting how impressive it is
and how unusual it is so the typescript
this is a duck typing by the way so duck
type I I liked that and also the fact
that it looks like clipart from my
homework in the 90s so gradual typing
normally you would associate gradual
typing with as at use you would think it
of it as a negative thing so normally
the opposite of gradual typing would be
the soundness of your types so being
able to say ahead of time that something
can only compile if it's soundly typed
whereas Java scripts because it's the
base of the typescript project and is
such a dynamic language applying the
types gradually and because the
semantics of Java scripts are so clearly
defined you're not dealing with the same
class of issues if you were dealing with
something where you needed soundness for
example if you're dealing with direct
memory access or something like that
then it makes sense to think about
soundness as the primary goal however
when you're dealing with something like
JavaScript a higher level of abstraction
applying the types very gradually allows
you to be incredibly flexible around the
approach and empowers tooling like we
just saw the type system is structural
and here the opposite would be a nominal
type system for example like in Java but
here we have structural typing which you
might think of as duck typing and the
the concept of duck typing is if it
quacks like a duck and it walks like a
duck it must be a duck so if you have a
shape in your program and you have
something else which can match that
shape almost like a contract does it
match the shape then you can say that it
passes type checking so this allows us
to do very simple things like the
interfaces you might have seen in
typescript
you can say I can implement that
interface as long as I have these two
methods that this interface requires
then it works so the structure is more
important as we've seen there's a lot of
inference that happens in typescript
it's able to infer from the way that you
write your program so that means that
the type annotations are not a
requirement you don't your typescript
programs don't need to look wildly
different from your JavaScript programs
you don't need to annotate every single
variable it can infer the types quite
well but then when you do need to go as
far as expressing very complex
situations for example if you're a
library author or a framework author you
might need to express very reusable
functions which take multiple types of
inputs suffer that so the type system
can be very very expressive when you
when you need it to be so the typescript
compiler is the thing that powers all of
this stuff it's the TSC binary that
we've seen executed already the TSE does
a couple of different roles
it's the emitter so it's the thing that
takes my JavaScript source it turns it
into an AST and it emits some other
transformed version of that code that's
what it does through as a transpiler so
it's a it's a particular type of
compiler at a particular level of
abstraction it also performs the role of
type checking for you and it's
configured variety as config JSON file
so the type script project itself has
got lots of moving parts but the TSC is
our entry point into it's the only thing
we wouldn't really need to worry about
we installed types
and we have access to the TSC command
one thing that I had enabled because I
started the project with TSE in it is
strict type checking I cannot impress on
you enough how important it is that you
have strict true set in your TS config
compiler options the reason for this is
particularly the Tet the check called
strict null checks this was introduced
in version 2 of typescript and
essentially before version 2 null and
undefined were subtypes of every other
type meaning they could be assigned to
any other type so if you had a number or
something like that
you could you could null it you could
set it to null and that would be a valid
assignment because null was a subtype of
number and that led to the typescript
compiler not being able to class a whole
category of bugs for you ahead of time
so it's not worse than JavaScript
JavaScript lets you do those assignments
all the time because it's dynamically
types but until the until null and
undefined became their own distinct
types type so it wasn't able to help you
as much as it is today so strict is
basically an umbrella flag which sets
lots of other flags behind the scenes so
you can configure these manually if you
want but strict is a really useful flag
because it not only ops you in to true
for all of the existing strict Flags it
also also automatically opts you into
the future ones
so whenever typescript introduces new
features which improve the type checking
they'll also massively be turned on
because they're under the strict
umbrella as well if that were to happen
and it breaks your codebase and you
think I want to upgrade but I don't have
time to fix this now what you can do is
you can keep the strict true but you can
actually toggle off individual checks
within that so for example if you added
strict function types I think that
should actually they had a problem with
this at Google when they upgraded strict
function types would have been too
painful for them to fix before the
upgrade so they actually kept strict
true on and they disabled strict
function types temporarily so
particularly strict null checks I would
make sure you have that on but no
implicit any is also a very useful one
under the strict flag if you can have a
stricture enabled make sure you do
one thing I've talked about a little bit
is the language service this is another
part the typescript project this is a
node server basically that runs anywhere
so we know it as running in the
background of Visual Studio code but
there's no reason why it can't run
anywhere it's used by any editor or IDE
that leverages typescript so it
basically keeps a cache of the way that
your program looks and as you're typing
it makes the minimal possible updates to
that cached value so that's why it can
give you sub 100 millisecond feedback
that's their design goal is sub 100
milliseconds because that's the point at
which humans start to get annoyed that
things aren't instantaneous so that's
why it's updates as quickly as possible
to give you that feedback so that's why
as I was typing I got a red squiggly
line or it fixed the red squiggly line
as soon as I'd finished typing so very
quickly another thing on that topic so
number two here I've got a type script
file it's wildly different from my last
example because I'm very inventive
this time it's lower casing my last name
instead of upper casing my first name so
this is just typescript now we're doing
with the typescript project which I've
configured with the TS config JSON I
have basically just copied the tierce
config from the last example except this
time I'm just compiling my whole sauce
with the typescript files in it as you
can see here I have got my jeaious doc
annotation in here I haven't added a
type annotation to the s yet and because
we're in typescript here the the process
of the jurist organization isn't quite
the same you can see these three dots as
well that have appeared underneath my L
so that's kind of interesting so if I
hover over that you can see that it's
giving me the feedback the J's top doc
types may be moved to typescript types
this because we're in a typescript
context so we can we can be more clear
about we're using these comments for
type information reasons so what we
could do here is if we highlight the
thing that is causing the error and we
get that feedback on it's not very big
but if you press command
full-stop in your editor or this you can
obviously trigger this by the command
prompt you can actually trigger a fix in
in a lot of cases now so if I do
annotate with type from Jo stock that is
going to add the type annotation from
here in explicitly to my program so
that's really cool it can apply if it
can give you feedback that you can
improve and it can also give you
automatic fixes this is all powered by
that language service now that I've got
the explicit type annotation again I
found the bug gets the same bug this is
a different method name so I can fix
that
I can fix that or I can let typescript
fix it for me so I can do the same exact
thing change spelling into lower case
was the suggested fix so I can just tell
typescript to fix it for me and these
automated fixes apply in so many
different ways if you are using imports
and exports and you start using a symbol
which you have an imported yet type
script can automatically import that for
you and add it to your program it can do
things such as fixing things on classes
adding missing this words keywords
that's best that kind of stuff it can do
all kinds of fixes and this is a key
area of growth that's happened in the
last six months to a year make your
slides so we spoke a little bit about
some of the the the journey to get here
and we've spoken about some of the
moving parts that power all of this
tooling how easy it is to get started
with with a JavaScript through the
typescript compiler I would say the
recent developments and the future is
about doubling down on that community
aspect so one really important
development that's happened recently
pause for dramatic thing is that Babel
now supports typescript passing inside
of its babel parser this used to be
called babylon it's been renamed they
now use the at babel namespace so i part
of the babel of typescript effort but
Andy from the Microsoft typescript team
did almost all of the work he was a hero
for that stuff so he such a cool F of
collaboration he was able to work from
Microsoft contribute to Babel he even
improved the Babel codebase as he was
going along which was the Babel codebase
leverages the flow type so there's no
hint of all we need to rewrite this in
typescript it's all about collaboration
so
really really cool improved the babble
codebase and added support for
typescript passing now since that core
work was done other people from the
community are now contributing to it in
Babel version 7 which which was released
about a month ago maybe 2 months ago
that's when that support landed so you
can now install a plug-in and a preset
inside of Babel and it will basically
work in the exact same way it works with
flow type right now it will strip your
type annotations away any syntax which
you have in your program which is not
valid JavaScript it will strip it away
so it doesn't replace the typescript
compiler it replaces the first bullet
point I had on the TSC page it replaces
the emitter from the typescript compiler
so it will handle transforming your
source code into your output your dist
the thing you want to ship it won't type
check for you it won't tell you if
you've made some of those mistakes like
I showed with the method name being
wrong you will also need to run the
typescript compiler but just as its type
checker function so you can set no omit
on the typescript compiler to not make
it output javascript files and you can
run it in the background as a type
checker so this just helps people who
are coming from different stacks
different code bases to get started with
with typescript it's all about lowering
those barriers to entry so that's a
really cool development and something
which will only continue to grow
definitely typed I wouldn't speak too
long about this but basically it's a
huge community effort this is growing
and growing and growing it's the most
single most active project don't get hub
in 2017 s crazy 42,000 commits from over
5,000 committers and the way that it all
works seamlessly is incredible when
stuff gets merged into definitely typed
so this these are the basically the DTS
files the the the way that you if you
use lodash or something like that a
javascript library which was written
with no knowledge of typescript these
are the types which community members
have written which get overlaid in the
typescript compiler to say oh you're
using lodash get well that has this
signature those are maintained in this
giant repo and then they're published to
npm automatically to the app types
namespace so if you want to add
typescript types to your lodash code you
would install app types slash lodash and
that would give you some
information which the type's compiler
can say oh there's the JavaScript
there's the Taipings I'll just overlay
those on top one really important
development was switching to a
predictable release cadence in the past
new versions would come out
out of the blue basically you wouldn't
know that they were coming they might
have large changes in them they wouldn't
be very predictable so it really helps
for large organizations particularly
when they can predict okay in a couple
of months we'll have the next version it
will therefore be relatively small
bite-sized I can I can upgrade without
two minutes from the issues clear
upgrade past clear blog posts from the
relief from the release and they work as
I mentioned a few times in close
collaboration with use code so that
means that when vs code releases it will
have the latest and greatest typescript
version they work together there's no
surprises but if you're feeling
adventurous you can always work on the
latest and greatest a lot of people do
do this and a lot of a lot of the issues
are caught very early on as a result
typescript that next allows you to bring
down the latest and greatest from the
project one recent development is around
how do you scale things like giant mono
repos often you might have something
which is rebuilt a lot of times in order
to power other things you might have a
dependency graph which one of the nodes
is particularly intense in how many
other nodes depend on it so the actual
source of the inspiration for this was
the typescript compiler itself the
project the typescript project itself so
here you can see the compiler sat in
here and this has actually built five
times during a typescript build so if
you were to run a build on the
typescript project the compiler would
have to be built five times because of
all the other things that depend on it
so that what they realized was that you
they can use the outputted DTS file of a
particular input so let's say the
compiler the public API of the compiler
if that doesn't change why do I need to
rebuild it for the other things so
that's what they realized they could use
the outputted DHCS file as a source of
truth so basically they've got this new
concept called project so you have to
wire it up in your TS config JSON to
reference the things that depend on
things but it's not too much extra
configuration and then you benefit
so now when they run a build the
typescript compiler only gets built once
and everything else knows it doesn't
need to be rebuilt so that's it it went
from I think four minutes to 30 seconds
or something the build so really really
cool development and if you have that
kind of project or if you have a large
mono repo this is definitely something
you want to check out the roadmap if
you're curious to learn more about
what's coming very soon is available on
the github repo on the wiki tab or you
can jump to that URL some of the things
that to call out are equi script
proposals so I mentioned that they
really want to stay close to ACMA script
and not invent their own features but it
it means they need to keep a close eye
on what is actually coming so when
things reach stage three of the ACMA
script proposal process in other words
they're one away from being implemented
the big int is one such example it's
reached stage three so that is the point
at which it will be considered to be
implemented in typescript so they'll be
implementing support for the big in
syntax and then kind of some legacy
stuff typescript had decorators and
private fields on classes way before
they existed in an ECMO script context
and a JavaScript context they now do
exist in a JavaScript techni script
context they're not fully published in
the spec yet but they are they're very
very close so at some point typescript
is going to need to support decorators
as they exist in JavaScript and the
private fields because they're they're a
little bit different there's no private
keywords in the JavaScript version
there's like a hash symbol and stuff
like that so some stuff they won't break
old typescript code bases of course but
they'll need to be an alternative way of
writing that I think or at least at the
very least and emit appreciation for
that and many many more refactoring
helpers auto fixes some of my favorites
I've seen recently other than the ones I
demoed you can take promise based code
where you've used chained bends and
caches you can now automatically
refactor them to use async await for
example so they'll be adding lots and
lots of fixes and Auto refactoring
helpers I think
and that's they'll be coming very very
soon thank you
[Applause]